out of all your years with the Lakers
what was your favorite championship year
probably the first one because after all
we've been through with Phil we almost
let it slip away no this is the game
seven vers Portland okay we were down I
think 15 to 17 points he came he said
all right guys I'm proud of you guys
Shaq you got to me being Prime but we're
not going to win this game today he was
like testing us to see if we wanted to
quit Co was like nah we just kept cut it
to 10 cut it to nine and I'm telling
Cove the whole game when you get to the
rim instead of doing all that I'm right
there I'm right there and and that
played every every body talks about he
cross pipping up and he threw it up and
he threw the mother up too high yeah he
threw it up too high but I'm I'm
stopping time if I miss this and we lose
gonna be my fault that go get
that down this game over okay I got two
days off I'm getting 40 in game one in
the finals I don't give a who we playing
I'm getting so I was able to to take
that moment and get back so that that
was a good
[Music]
one